just climate justice my daughter's here
and i'm here to support her as a climate
because we don't want the world to
shrivel up if we care about our future
generations and we need this size to be
taken seriously
this is our world we really need to do
something about it before it's too late
wait till we stop voting for you based
on your empty promises
[Music]
let's see i think we have people over
profit i think a green new deal would
help a lot of people especially in rural
areas in america which is where i'm from
um and so yeah that way we can make
people's lives better while helping the
environment climate change
disproportionately affects certain
communities and that we cannot achieve
climate change without addressing racial
justice social justice and inequity
uh start with a great new deal
then try to make our cities less car
dependent we can't really solve climate
change we're driving as much as we are
and most people are forced to drive as
much as they are because of the way that
our cities are designed
the climate uh policies that are being
advocated for
have environmental justice and climate
justice intersection and that the
communities that are most um inequally
burdened by pollution and climate change
are the communities that should be
prioritized for mitigation and
investments ban fossil fuels for one
rely on american sustainable energy
[Music]
one thing subsidizing more fruits and
vegetables instead of meat and dairy
that meets the environment
the fact that our politicians including
democrats do not seem to really care
about climate change they only pretend
to care about it when it's useful for
them winning votes
i hope that modern would you know stop
contracts with the fossil fuel industry
and limit the amount of big money in
politics just overall
we need to be in line with the paris
climate accords in reducing greenhouse
gases by 50
by 2030 and net zero by 2050.
i want him to prioritize human life and
stop without money
oh you have this world only come on
we're so much better than this we're so
much smarter than that let's do it